we really confused a lot of people
because we spoke on that episode about
which microphone you use and then how to
use the zoom mic
yep it's classic
you picked up the usb mic and you were
like see this is the one you hear me
through and everyone was like that's the
one i'm hearing you through it was great
it was going through my laptop so it's
[ __ ] on my side this side this weekend
at least six episodes already kind of
fine
[Music]
what was weird is that i don't think
i've ever had that particular type of
error
that i got that canceled it i don't
think i've ever had that during one of
these you have to be run it's basically
pro tools going
there's too much going on and i'm
freaking out if you have like a thousand
plugins and reverbs and all kinds of
things and it's literally just a session
with one audio channel
and the microphone it's it's the most
bare bones it would be the equivalent of
like opening word and making a period
going pro tools had a panic attack
because we called it out we were talking
about it true it's not used to the
spotlight and so it freaked out
yeah and it just gave up
um i think that's the case
well i'm gonna babysit it this time that
sounds great otherwise we can use zoom
let me hang on let me record it just in
case
[ __ ] i almost forget about that can't
it's fine i have the desktop audio um
austin you
had an exciting announcement
over the past week
uh i did i uh
i uh journey turned ten
and so i did something completely insane
um
which was a self-produced
uh album with the london symphony
which is what i was doing in london when
we were recording over christmas and i
was in a mystery hotel room
um
and uh yeah it was uh i'm actually
amazed and thrilled that the whole thing
actually
kind of came off how it did because i i
don't mean i don't mean the release but
just the actual sessions
because as you recall christmas was
basically when omicron decided to
completely explode all throughout london
or the uk in general well the world
really but but uk was in a particular
state um
and
uh the the we had put the session on the
books months earlier
and
the um
the lso was like well we're basically
you know it was the question became is
it going to get canceled and the lso
said well
we're going to basically aggressively
test everyone every day uh kind of like
a film set you know where you've got
um
just constant rotation of people being
tested
um
and also
do you know kind of
rely on the orchestra to also kind of
police themselves uh in a sense which is
pretty easy to do when they're a very
cohesive group that spends all their
time together year after year after year
after year there's a lot of internal
camaraderie so it was kind of thing
where right that's very similar to how
film and tv are currently operating
whereas like game dev we're just not
seeing each other
well and and
and there's also like it would be the
game dev equivalent might be a studio
that has been in existence for a real
long time because basically the way that
they approached it was
if you
like say your husband or wife
at home were to get it or to even just
think they have it yes
um
then it would be like you know
flag it
you know try to rapid test if you can't
um we'll just sub in a musician you know
at the 11th hour to replace you so that
you don't so that even if you might have
it you won't come in
uh so they were they were keeping real
close eye on everybody um because we had
a huge orchestra 91 piece orchestra and
so there was like you know there's a lot
of opportunity theoretically but they
were real on top of it we didn't have a
single
um situation single case same thing the
choir we had a 32 voice choir at the end
the london voices
amazing group i hadn't worked with them
since we did abzu and they're just so
unbelievable it's one thing to watch an
orchestra play music that they've never
rehearsed but it's another to see a
choir
just
sing with zero preparation
um and it's just amazing so yeah they
they we because singing is kind of like
the worst possible thing you can do
um if you're trying to prevent covet
spread the early days like some of the
super spreader events
yeah yeah like maximally projecting
um
so of course the choir obviously we
tested very aggressively as well but
then they also spaced them out in a way
normally a choir would be very shoulder
to shoulder so that everyone can hear
each other very conscientiously but they
said ah
they're superhuman what's it matter so
we spaced everyone so every member of
the choir was like in they they
literally drew
uh with like a measuring stick uh on the
on the floor of the hall so that every
person had like this eight to nine foot
radius at all in all directions before
they found the nearest person so the
result was that everyone had to really
really listen to each other and then to
kind of to kind of offset does that make
your job harder
it makes their job a lot harder from my
point of view
not particularly um
under different circumstances it might
but it doesn't affect things like line
of sight to me it just
cause even spread out 32 of them it was
still a third the size of the orchestra
true it just was like it was 32 of them
over almost the same
square footage as the orchestra which
was what was interesting about it the
choir was just so spread out
um
but can i ask her can i ask a question
about this like in terms of all right so
thank you
i'm rusty i've missed i just never
understood that you know i ask like
british
when in the history of conversation has
somebody in all earnestness been like
if i'm really brutally i'd rather you
didn't
well normally you throw our tea in the
water and it causes a whole hassle still
upset about that i see still upset my
mates took me to the boston team museum
and one of the people working there
thought i was doing a voice to take the
piss
hilarious the
uh the uh you don't have to travel far
to see uh museums about whole foods
legit almost just spilled my coffee over
that good well there you go it's quite
comfortable circle so my question was
like from a creative point of view like
what was
what was the formation of this idea is
it is it achieving things that you
couldn't do 10 years ago is it um just a
celebration like what was the kind of
driving energy behind this forward the
short version the kind of elevator pitch
was that um
i
because the journey
sort of
player community
has been just outrageously
supportive the last 10 years like i've
i've worked on a lot of games and i've
i've
been part of games that like built
communities you know like the banner
saga and i've been i've also stepped
into existing communities like
assassin's creed
um and
you know i've always been
generally very lucky i've never really
gotten you know i've never gotten [ __ ]
from groups as a default position
there's always been like the outlier you
know uh why you're messing up the
franchise or whatever but generally
people people tend to be just generally
pretty good to
the video game music contingent as a
general state um mostly because most
people just don't notice us so those
that do
uh are very nice but um but journey has
always been
very unusual it's just like
that the reaction that game got
um was so
almost like religious i mean it was very
hot
absolutely intense
and wonderful community reaction and i
guess because the music is so
inordinately exposed in the gameplay
relative to most games the conversion
rate of like journey player to journey
music
well-wisher is very very high relative
to normal games so seemingly everyone
who ever played the game
you know tweeted or emailed or
came to a concert at some point or you
know bought a vinyl or whatever it's
just been and so for 10 years and it
never and it never stopped i should say
so for 10 years i've been
just
this continuous recipient of really
really
generous
kindness
from
from folks and so i found myself i don't
know i don't know maybe six months ago i
thought
um
the game is going to turn 10 which is
its own surreal
thing to think about doesn't seem like
it could possibly have been that long
ago
but i found myself just wanting to just
to
offer up something that could
hopefully give even an approximation of
the gratitude that i feel to that
community of folks like there is part of
course it would be cool if the album
catalyzes new people discovering it but
in a way it's sort of like their bonus
and they're really not my focus it's for
those of you that already
kind of
made those overtures how how can i make
it clear to you that i wouldn't have a
career without you like you can't
force people to
like a thing and when they like a thing
of their own volition
um it raises the profile of that thing
and when that
reaches a sufficient kind of
fever pitch
the industry takes notice and like that
sequence of events is literally why i
know the two of you why i know troy why
every job i've gotten there's i don't
think there's a single job that i've
gotten in games since journey came out
that isn't somehow predicated on having
been the guy that did journey yeah and
so it's like i owe them basically
everything because it wouldn't have been
that if it hadn't been for the community
it's because you know
very few games
sorry go ahead
i was just going to ask alana did
anything massive happen in your life in
2012 because for me for you for you
journey for me thomas was alone is
coming up to 10 years
was there something for you working at
xbox i got my job at xbox in 2012. so
2012 2012 was a good thing it was my
first page
yeah
um graduated high school 2010
2012. those aztecs didn't know [ __ ]
um i have two questions the first is i
want to backtrack a tiny bit and um
can you can you advertise it properly
tell me exactly what this thing is and
where people can find it
um it's called traveler which is clearly
named after choice son
that's where he's that's got to be where
the idea came from right actually funny
enough it's not
there's never been an official name
for the character in journey some people
call it the companion some people call
it the wanderer some people call it the
traveler
i just kind of latched on to traveler um
because i liked it but i am not
but i could have called it anything
theoretically and it would have been
equally canon and it definitely was
predates
uh choice
son
and also that's not why troy named his
son that it's just kind of two things in
orbit
uh i guess but um uh or or rather not in
orbit kind of adjacent but in any case
that uh
traveler
um
uh is the name a journey symphony for
the record i actually didn't
that name was somewhat
uh
mutually agreed upon as part of my
agreement with sony well that was going
to be my second question so i'll let you
answer this also seo wise
yeah my second was going to be what does
this agreement look like but um yeah i
mean they were wise to say the original
album title that i pitched um
was traveler an austin wintery story
exactly [ __ ] you ratchet
yeah originally called a traveler a star
wars story and for some reason
[Laughter]
disney also kind of raised their
eyebrows but uh no it was it was um i
originally had a different name but they
were they were like you know
everybody including you would do well to
make sure that it's not confusable with
the original album
um
and that's true uh so uh after after
thinking
you know i'm i'm terrible with names
i've always struggled to find it to find
a name that really seems to to fit it
but then just realizing oh just traveler
and then i literally the subtitle is
just purely to make it very obvious that
it's not a random piece of music called
traveler that's just one of those like
in an ideal world it'd be this very pure
album cover that just says traveler or
something like that or the traveler
but but uh the actual album cover is uh
art from angela correct
yeah
it's really nice really beautiful i i
will make sure that she she hears your
your kind words she she really sweat
bullets over it because she felt this
this huge pressure and you know oh
that's very thank you it's incredible
she um
you know we met because she did a
journey cosplay and that was like by far
the best anyone had ever done and it
just like came a lot of effort to go to
for a date though isn't it
worked out no well the hilarious thing
was
the funny thing was hey what it was a
sound investment sadness
investment in sound that has turned out
to be true
um but it was all very innocent uh she
she was going to egypt uh for a
convention to judge a cosplay contest
they were flying her out and when she
kind of put in two two and two together
she was like oh if i'm going to be in
egypt i should i should do a journey
cosplay so like basically the night
before
she whipped up this costume and managed
to somehow fit it in her suitcase
and went into the sand dunes outside of
cairo and shot um this journey cosplay
that went super viral online because it
was just the caliber of her costume and
the caliber of the photographer's work
combined into something insane so sony
santa monica's twitter at some point i
think tagged me to be like check this
out and i
saw it and was blown away and so i just
reached out to say you know you're
amazing and then i discovered she was a
painter
and uh then i said let's collaborate and
and we started collaborating and doing
live things and then you know it must be
super cool for her too that she got to
do the art for the
well that was it was very she she saw it
as almost like a burden in the best way
because it was like like a like a
responsibility she she held it and she
holds matt nava the artist you know who
was the art director on journey he's
like one of our heroes
and you know he developed such an iconic
look for that game and it through such
simple means it's such a minimalist
aesthetic and and he did such an amazing
job
so she felt this like
you know kind of responsibility to do
something that
that could hold its own in that regard
but and sort of leverage the iconic
stuff but also it couldn't look like the
original album in any way and the
original leans so heavily on kind of the
classic look of the
of the game the sort of golden orange
sand and desert and yellows and the
little avatar the character and so it
was like how do you make an album that
says okay we're revisiting this
uh and it's clearly sort of reborn and
reimagined it's not just reorchestrated
it it really is can you explain how it's
different to the original album what's
why why should i have both
[Laughter]
uh
you are invited to uh should
but um
um
it's so what it is
here's my
one of the recurring sentiments
that has come up over the years like
people tweeting this or
coming up to me randomly and going
of all the games i wish i could go back
in time and kind of erase my memory and
play again
this would be the one
i've heard that a lot and i've always
loved that idea i remember the first
time i ever thought about that idea was
in 1997 when they were re-releasing the
star wars trilogy and patrick stewart
was on tv going of all the movies i wish
i could watch for the first time again
it would be star wars
and that planted that seed of like oh
that's that's a very wonderful kind of
way to
to kind of revere something is to to go
i would love to
to erase the memory of it and feel it
all new again
and
journey has just been that there's just
i don't know there's people out there
who
said that's their one i get tagged all
the time this is my one if i could do
that that would be it
and so i thought well you know we can't
obviously do that but if i were to kind
of re because the game leans so much on
the music if i were to sort of redo the
music where it's different enough that
it actually is fresh to you to a to a
seasoned listener to somebody that knows
that music
it would feel new because it is in a
very literal sense it's new but it's
obviously not
a new piece of music from the ground up
it has all that original dna still so it
kind of sorta fulfills that fantasy of
i get to sort of have this thing i
already know as if it was for the first
time that was my my wish uh
that i that it could hopefully offer to
folks that's just like
as one big thank you to being a
wonderful group so then the other
aspects how much planning actually goes
like oh my god it took months like i i
when i spoke to grant because you uh
missed an episode of the show
we spoke about uh reed jiggy which was
him basically recreating a lot of
jiggy's i love the accent
how would you say it rejiggered
but it's jigged
is there not an r and how he
normally you reach oh yeah you read
it's rejigging you would have said
he would have said rejigging it's all e
yeah i guess i have to look forward to
him being on here again
i've earned i've earned another his
approach was very uh like he wanted to
take some of the songs and and put them
into different genres uh entirely um so
they sound very different and he didn't
enjoy the process of doing that from uh
that's funny yeah he found it really
frustrating in a lot of ways like how to
figure out how to do that exactly so
yeah what when how i don't know how do
you approach this kind of thing how long
does it take and how do you make
the changes where you make them like i
just don't understand where you even
start it was it was it was hard and i
had to reel myself back a bunch of times
because
so the original people think of the
original as orchestral because it has
like a group of strings at the end of
the game
um
which is like 20 we had about a 21 piece
string ensemble complementing the
solo cello and stuff for the finale of
the game and you hear those strings
hinted at successively like larger
bite-sized pieces from about the
one-third mark until you reach the final
15 minutes of the game and then the
strings kind of carry it well strings
are kind of like the bare minimum that
you could have to label something as
orchestral um
but in my mind
it's not really i mean i don't know i
don't really care about the sort of
label sort of accuracy but it in my mind
it's not really an orchestral score it's
it's almost borderline new age music
because it's like super reverb cello
cello and synth pads it's hopefully like
good because new age to me doesn't
always carry the best connotation
um
but it's like i don't blame people for
calling it that they super chill you
know super kind of
you know laid back and all that that you
associate with with new age music and so
the idea was what if we made it
symphonic like a big giant
orchestra and so i realized if you
called the old one
new age the new one is almost like a
ghibli
or miyazaki-esque approach of because
there's a lot of emotional similarity
with the in the in a typical miyazaki
film it's actually rather similar
emotional kind of landscape as a game
like journey but when you express that
through a giant lush orchestra it feels
very different than if it's just
you know solo cello and harp and and
then maybe and a lot of like synth pads
and
and so that was kind of the idea of not
that it's sort of a deliberate homage to
joey sayashi or anything like that but i
just i felt like how can i make
something that's lush and pretty and
and melancholy and introspective but
gigantic i mean the final total of
musicians is 134. um which is you know
91 piece orchestra is just about the
biggest that you would go for basically
any reason uh i mean there are bigger
ones i was at the avatar recording
sessions with james horner and i think
that was 108 piece orchestra so like
they're still sealing above 91 for sure
well you need you need one for each only
with avatar
exactly yeah that was the idea well the
funny thing was they also had about a
hundred singers separately you know
where they did a giant semi-circle along
the back
three walls of the room i wasn't there
for those sessions but i heard about it
pretty well pretty astonishing scope but
so this is
honestly almost that except musically
far more restrained like that that's
doing that because it wants to be
bombastic i was doing it because i
thought an orchestra that plays quietly
but there's a huge number of them has a
very special kind of magic that was sort
of the premise of the sound of the
banner saga score as well like
save the loud points as long as possible
so that this huge group of musicians
playing quietly feels like this massive
weight uh but difference being the
banner saga has no strings it's a giant
group of wind and brass only so that it
feels you know very like a funeral dirge
this this was supposed to be hopefully
very warm and very kind of um
uh lush in the in the more traditionally
almost classical
sense so yeah it was it was the other
aspect is you know
it was like this conspiracy of variables
where
i was
um
a few years ago the lso
reached out to me which was insane
because this is the bucket list for
every composers to work with the london
symphony the same musicians that
recorded star wars and recorded harry
potter and raiders of the lost ark and
shame that's expensive
uh it's not any more expensive than
recording in london is typically which
is basically the most expensive place to
record
um it's the most expensive place to do
anything in fairness
so
everything's [ __ ] expensive here on
every level well the ironic thing is if
you want to record a score la is more
expensive because the musicians union
mandates you to back-end royalty
payments whereas the london musicians
don't so it is long-term more expensive
to record in la which is why the only
ones that really do it these days are
the
long-term signatories that that it
you know signed union agreements a
better part of a century ago and the
legal ramifications of getting out of
them are just more of a pain in the ass
than going with the flow
um but all new studios generally don't
that's like you know that's why you know
uh
uh marvel for example has never recorded
in la once uh
only ever recorded in london but um
in any case uh the um
the london symphony had reached out to
me a number of years ago but most of
what i do is super weird i don't really
write traditional orchestral music very
often even the banner saga like i said
there was no strings
you know or or abzu is like seven harps
with sopranos and oboe and you know like
some wood like it it it's never really
the traditional symphonic orchestra like
if you went down to disney hall to see
the la phil or carnegie hall to see the
new york phil or whatever that
configuration of musicians which has a
very specific lineup of how many flutes
how many oboes like there's a very kind
of standardized set that you would refer
to as sort of the 19th century
modern symphony orchestra sound
um and i don't use that kind of ensemble
very often almost never
in fact all my music that i have that's
formatted to that is when someone
reaches out to say hey we'd like to do
journey live in concert we're the such
and such orchestra and so i made
standardized versions so that those
orchestras could just play them without
having to do a bunch of bending over
backwards to accommodate weird
instruments and stuff
and so
but writing from the beginning that way
super um
super unusual for me so that's why i was
unbelievably blown away when the lso
reached out said hey if you ever want to
work together here's our here's our
number that's a huge compliment oh it's
i don't even know how or why i came
across their radar i don't think they
explained they probably were just cold
calling a you know a fresh wave of
potential clients i don't want to over
uh sell myself i'm sure there was
nothing terribly special about me but it
was i had i had reached enough of a
profile that i caught their eye one way
or the other but i i remember thinking
i recorded london a lot but i don't
really know
when i would need you guys uh so i just
said let's keep in touch and then when i
was there right before the pandemic
with darren corb we were at abbey road
doing the super giant record the songs
of supergiant like sort of orchestral
reimaginings of the the greatest hits of
supergiant to celebrate their 10th
anniversary and i was also recording
pathless that same week um
there i invited their guy
mario from the lso to come hang out at
abbey road and we would just like have a
coffee during one of the breaks
it was kind of like yeah we should
definitely you know find something to do
and so my brain kind of
that was where i think the sort of
intermingling of those two different
things kind of started it was like 10th
anniversary that's fun and awesome
london symphony that's fun but that was
still early 2020 it wasn't a full fully
until like august of 2021 that it went
oh [ __ ] that's we're like six months
away from the 10th anniversary i really
should do something and then it all just
kind of popped and so then yeah how did
it work legally uh
what what do you do you have to get
permission from sony like how
so interesting in terms of ip
yeah it's interesting so as you might
imagine journey is owned by sony in
every sense including its music the
crazy thank you
so much
including cyberpunk now not far off um
they're just gonna just gave them that
while we're at it blue right now it's
gotten cheap there you go
um
so um i have a great relationship with
with them and and you know they were
always like when we did journey live as
a touring concert show where we would do
the whole game and we were playing it on
a ps4 dev kit that was had a custom
build with all the music removed so that
we could do the music live on stage
while the sound effects were in the
speakers
they've always been down for stuff like
that they've always been really you know
they're they're very
pro
creators you know they've never they
never do like dmca strikes when people
do covers of the music and put on
youtube and that kind of thing they've
always been
so i knew that i could go to them and
say
you know here's what i want to do and
they they'd be up for it but also just
the lengths we were going to and also
once you're involving a group like the
lso it's kind of racist
yeah you want to make sure that your
paperwork's pretty legit and not and not
just like an email from someone going
yeah you know cool have fun yeah but
it's like yeah let's take care of it so
the interesting question becomes
is this um
am i creating a derivative work
in which case i absolutely do need their
permission and a contract or am i making
a cover of music that is owned by
someone else even if i am in fact the
original i need to cover yourself
well because the i mean that's
effectively what grant was doing too
right um because
every best of album you've ever listened
to right is often a way of artists
re-recording their own work
yeah
and if you yeah if you don't control the
rights to it uh and you want to do a
thing like that the interesting thing
about a cover is you don't need
permission legally in the united states
to do a cover of and make money from it
and sell it and everything yeah
now that's why traveler 2 is out next
week
[Applause]
from from from bethel industries uh
stockholm
yeah the way it works is there's what's
called a like a statutory license or
like a sort of a compulsory license that
says if you if you've basically if you
have to file the paperwork the right way
and there's a couple of sort of
third-party entities that act as the
go-between that can help you do this you
can also i think just
file it directly with the library of
congress but that's way more cumbersome
which is why these third-party groups
exist but you basically have to pay a
royalty
um that's set by law
of to the original author or copyright
holder rather um
and as long as you pay that then you can
do literally whatever you want
and so it's it's now the one interesting
area where that's not true is
that wouldn't apply for example to
copyrighted or trademarked materials for
a cover art so like if i want to do a
cover of
you know
uh banjo-kazooie
uh i could do a cover musically all day
long but i don't think i could put banjo
on the st or on the like album cover
without getting permission um
so
well in his case he can probably just
call them and get permission um
there's no banjo on it it's just a blue
backpack
yeah so there you go that that would be
why
so in this case i i i did reach out to
sony and say you know i'd really like to
use
branded iconography for the album cover
i'd also just like to make an all-in you
know all-encompassing deal that
basically you know lets me
do whatever i want with this thing live
shows sell you know like these sheet
music books i always have like i can
sell one of those of this i could do
whatever i want and basically just i'll
just you know i'll cut you in on on
gross receipts that we that we
that we take with it and you know
they're always super um they're super on
board i mean they were much easier
well it if i hadn't
been hired by them and maintained a good
relationship for the last it's always
the relationship it's always the future
if the average kind of person off the
street went in and said hey sonya got a
cool idea for something we can do with
god of war wouldn't be quite so
successful whereas yeah but nintendo
would just chop your head off no matter
what you would make it into the building
you wouldn't make it into the building
at the nintendo i think
even with a good relationship yeah
nintendo's famously just so ultra
protective of their ip yeah
to an outrageous degree
sony is in a way the hard opposite they
they're they're they're very lucid they
seem to have i i'm not speaking for them
i've never heard them say this but it's
their actions would suggest that their
philosophy is
we
rip
is served by people engaging with it
it's less about the individual
transactions the money earned by
squeezing that random cover artist or
that copyright takedown
pales in comparison of just having a
community of people that are
sharing our ip around and keeping our
relevancy that is what it seems like no
idea i i i again no one's ever said that
to me out loud from sony i'm i could be
wrong uh but it just seems like
that's the they're making a long-term
investment
in just staying in people's hearts and
minds
uh and knowing that that eventually
leads to oh hey look there's a new
there's a new one of these games that's
coming out and i you know i've i've
stayed that game has stayed in a happy
place in my subconscious for the last 22
confirmed
that's what you're saying
everybody's been waiting for it my
favorite is i've seen multiple twitches
making it yeah this is what i'm doing at
sms well all that all that time you're
spending not working so yeah um
yeah those weekends yes honestly i get
people every time i do anything that's
not work which i'm naturally not allowed
to talk about
i get so much shouldn't you be working
on ragnarok every single time i'm like
is has this been happening
as we're talking right now i'm i i feel
like judgmental of you i am on my lunch
break how dare i not be working on
ragnarok i don't see you eating
this is i think i am
this is my lunch
this is very good
it is very bizarre
because
the thing that get this is totally an
aside the thing that gets done is
if i were to work constantly on one
thing the thing would get worse like the
more that you try to like bash your head
against one thing
the quality deteriorates you have to
have breaks where you do other [ __ ] to
be good in a creative space and that's
like mike i'm sure you'd agree on
writing i i know that every day i can
only write a certain amount before my
words turn into trash like i'm like i
job i can't do tired no
tired i've got a good three hours where
i like i know there's other periods of
time where i need to think about stuff
or i need to know it take or i need to
do whatever else but uh it's almost like
the people who are attacking you online
are not doing it in the best of faith
it's almost like it's true
but it happens to everyone from my
perspective it's like to all devs and
it's such a weird one where it's like if
they were to work on your on on the game
constantly the game would be worse not
faster it would just be [ __ ]
i think it's a lot to do as well with
the conception among a lot of players
and this isn't true of all players i
think players in general are getting
better at this but i think a lot of
people still think that
video game industry jobs are like cushy
jobs and they are i've had real jobs
like game development i prefer but they
are jobs like it is hard work you go
home at the end of the day knackered
like it is it is a job job i think
sometimes people just assume it's silly
and fun like while i'm not working i'm
still thinking about work constantly um
and many of the contracts actually cover
that yeah yeah yeah well in creative
work it's also you can't like
you can't increase the
conveyor belt speed to get more done on
creative work like you can if you crunch
austin and as a big proponent but that's
not even created that's what you know
that that's just like
somebody
[ __ ] something out because they have
to like crunch you can't i don't think
you can immediately becomes yeah it
immediately becomes worse as a result
yeah the failure of the constant failure
of crunch is actually a brilliant
demonstration exactly what you're saying
that there is a there is a cap and
that's been borne out in various studies
and research but even well before you
reach the threshold of what you could
call crunch like
i remember once someone asked the coen
brothers how do you guys consistently
write such great scripts
and they said we take a lot of naps
uh you know it's like this idea that
you have to you know or when you're
stargazing you know you if you kind of
look
to either side of the stars sometimes
you can actually see them better
um
as your as your eye sort of focuses on
the dark part and then lets more light
in
and so
the
the the the subconscious cooking of an
idea yeah is a process that's
you can't muscle your way through that
you know like there is a lot of craft i
think it gets harder the more you try to
muscle your way through creative work
like if you're if you're frustrated or
you feel directionless and you just try
to push yourself through it and you
don't take the time to like organize
your thoughts it gets worse and messier
in many ways uh
uh this journey album
was kind of that for me because
obviously i i was finishing
paid work uh through the end of last
year and had deadlines and all kinds of
things that of course i
you know was staying on top of but
anytime i needed you know okay i i need
to take an hour away from from this
i would then go work on the journey
arrangements uh because it it was like
win-win i would be coming into the
journey arrangement with my mind
thinking about something completely
unrelated
uh and then and then meanwhile you know
then circling back to that other thing
with nothing but journey in my head i'm
looking at it with fresh eyes and so
even if i'm just alternating within two
different musical tasks obviously it's
all the more so if i then
you know go do something that's
completely unrelated to music at all but
within a working day i could i could i
could smuggle it in and it would
actually improve
the thing i was
on the clock for
i couldn't do what lana does of kind of
writing all day like i'm to be like it's
true what you just said about kind of
only having so many hours of writing in
you is that's too extreme with me like
the reason i'm able to like do my job is
that my job is like 10 different jobs
and if i'm bored all right you know
tired on one job i can switch course to
a different job like the the fact that
like yeah if i actually had to focus on
writing
five days a week as my as my only focus
i think i'd go insane i think i need
like i'm gonna do two hours of writing
right now then i've gotta talk to a
couple of the artists for a couple of
hours to figure out some stuff for them
and then i'm gonna go and do a financial
meeting and then i've gotta talk to a
partner you know it's like it's a good
you also have to talk to that stephanie
oh i know sorry i apologize i didn't
mean i did not understand what you're
doing
the focus the focus i guess the focus
being on story always i assume for you
and that's the yeah sometimes sometimes
it just gets very like overwhelming like
in a way that's just like
definitely um talking artist does rule
though big fan of that i love working
with artists it's like oh my amazing
that's been my favorite thing about
working in game
and it can reignite you as well i had we
we've been recruiting like crazy
recently and and i got to see some like
art tests from like new artists who i've
not worked with yet and just like seeing
like a new eyes you've not worked with
like just come in and do something
interesting play with it's just oh it's
so amazing um and you'll have been you
all have been
you'll have been at sony long enough now
that you're probably seeing artists
executing on stuff you've written
correct and seeing like that's amazing
the best it's so sick
i love it so much i wrote a word and now
there's a thing yeah yeah and they make
it so much better like so always i had
this uh last weekend at this point was
the video game accessibility awards
which i was working on
well that's what i was gonna say
actually is so i wrote scripts for
everybody and you know submitted them to
all the presenters and watching ryan
reynolds read the script was my first
moment where i've written stuff for
actors before but the first time that i
was like holy [ __ ] [ __ ] like
i wrote every word he said and you would
never think that i did you would think
that he just had notes and then pulled
it out of his ass he might he either
memorized it or was reading it from a
teleprompter but i was like jesus christ
watching like an actor like that take
words and and to be fair i did write
that with him in mind so like i sure had
written it being like this one's gonna
be ryan so i'll write it with how it was
mostly plagiarized from deadpool exactly
yeah that's mostly just a doubt that's
the
oh my god
so i was like oh he did like you took
something that i wrote that was like
fine and then you made it so like candid
and natural to the extent that people
were like you wrote that did you even
write the jokes i was like yeah he just
said them now he doesn't yeah he is he
is the classic movie star of someone
who's
so like talented at the process that
people just assume he's winging it like
it did
with rod rounds it's that movie
anything you've ever had
assume he's acting yeah he's so you know
he's hot he's funny he's charming he
didn't do anything he was like put to
bed i was like no
i've never seen anybody do this this
well before like it's nuts i mean you
must feel like that mic when you see
actors who are actually good bring your
words to life because i've just not like
not had that to this exactly
oh you've not been yeah i've
i i
it's fascinating it's also fascinating
when you work with an actor who's
completely out of your league so like um
ryan reynolds like
well i don't know i don't know i'm being
self-deprecating but i wouldn't
criticize you
the uh like like ian mcshane definitely
like ian mcshane was was like i
remember him going he was doing his
performance and him taking a line and
going so were you going for that mike or
should we change that to that it's like
i think we should change that to that
that's a good that's a good note um or
um andy circus like such a soft way of
telling you it's terrible yeah no and it
was and he was so kind like it was just
such a sweet process with him and then
something like andy circus where it's
the opposite thing of like just working
recording with him for a session and
then and then him getting to like you
know page 30 of the script kind of
looking it through before he's about to
record it doing a little chuckle going
oh that's uh that's quite good mike and
he's like oh this is making my life
worthwhile it's great working with
people who are more talented than you is
just i'm sure i've said it on the show
before but it's just 10 out of 10. just
it's the trick what's great is if you
start your own game company you can make
it an entire building of people smarter
than you it's amazing um i love it it's
genuinely yeah it's so cool and being
able to and what's very cool is it's
then self multiplying so once you've
like in our case like i you know started
the company got got a team of very
talented people around me and what's
cool is then you know nearly a decade
now later there are people coming in who
are
looking to work with us because of how
talented all the people who were here
before them
are and it kind of becomes this
self-fulfilling prophecy of like and you
know i'm i'm stood in the middle of it
just going yeah sure
can i get you something
that's right sorry that is lovely
neil druckmann told me once that there
were people working on the last of us
too
who the last of us won is what made them
want to pursue a career in games yeah
and like the idea that there was enough
time between those games my phone keeps
falling off my lap onto the floor uh
made it sound like your phone
has a i feel like that's a u problem
less of a phone problem no no it's my
fault because i move too much but if i
put it on the desk and then i get a text
or something you'll get a nice loud
vibration again self-conscious because
of that we know how the audience enjoys
those i'm just gonna put it over here uh
so
uh yeah the idea that those were far
enough apart from each other
that
the
like somebody could be inspired and make
this fundamental life choice to pursue
it and then have the opportunity for
that to come true to me was so cool that
was i've interviewed designers who
studied thomas was alone don't lie
it's true they don't tell you and it's
it's because he went to them and he was
like you have homework yeah it's like
you have to go you go and you study my
work before you
mean that it was taught in like game
design yeah game design degree well it's
also i know i know thomas alone is also
used in british schools with um to teach
kind of cooperation and kindness and
stuff for like oh that's earlier ages
very cool it's even i think it's used
it's actually used in some prisons as
well i think for the same reason
so i like to think that like some really
badass heists have been pulled off
thanks to the lessons of thomas
almost definitely
yeah that is that is super cool like
it's
aging wow
aging keeps happening
2012 was a magical year like it's it's
yeah i legitimately think 2012 was the
first year that i got paid for any kind
of video game industry shenanigans what
was this what was troy 2012
well not freelancing sorry volunteering
by a shot and find out what troy was
saying
no no no infinite was the year after
troy baker i'm gonna i guarantee troy
was doing something the last of us come
out in 2012
i think it was i think i thought it was
the next year
also um not sure where troy is
yeah actually i messaged him uh just
generally relatedly i messaged him to
see if he uh was going to be able to
join us or not he he is he is not in
he is out of
town at the moment so it would have been
another one of these remote pockets
but i thought he was going to be able to
make it it's because i was going to say
i um
he was there in london he came and sat
in while we recorded the orchestra and
literally sat there in the room 10 feet
away while they record it for the whole
experience of it
um
and um
he did scooby doo mystery incorporated
from 2010 i was going to say the answer
to my question is he was in everything
in 2012. he also did the avengers that's
mightiest heroes generator binary domain
binary nfl
guardians
ultimate spider-man you're right kyle is
it kind of like that
highland 2012. there you go scooby-doo
spooky games i'm i just feel like we're
glossing over scooby-doo here
troy had a very scooby-doo heavy year
2012.
i didn't know he played he played a
character called additional voices in
like 10 games that yeah
and every year after he did yeah it's
like a metaverse thing
he was batman in lego batman 2.
he did dark side his two guild wars 2
resident evil 6
he in a professor leighton game
no
what
you know that's like the most excited
i've been about any of troy's secret
roles is professor layton are you
[ __ ] playing a playing character
called alphonse dalton i wonder what
accent he did
i [ __ ] love professor leighton he's
in halo for black ops 2
scott you know what it just he wasn't
gonna wear ascension
i feel like i should have known that
anyway did they not tell you that
orientation or like i just thought about
you he was in the last one didn't know
he was in an ascension as well
three i didn't know that is he
he's he plays like a [ __ ] guy
i have to say to that to that uh point
you were making about the actors though
and in the spirit of like those same
that he and that cadre of folks that are
in so many things
the the laura baileys and mary elizabeth
mcglinn's and ashley johnson's and like
we're working on this musical uh right
now with the leah messler david gator
one
and most of our cast is not announced so
i'll just keep it anonymous for the time
being like it's called chorus right the
one the one that uh yes is is chorus and
not chorus
that one is um
that game we have a lot of our cast is
amazing i can't wait to be able to like
reveal who who's in it but it's a lot of
these folks where you go
you know they're so well regarded
they're so well known
that surely they're just kind of like
celebrities more than they are talents
like they're your mind does this
gymnastics of like they're just so
omnipresent on social media and at
events and if you like google them
you got the job because you're popular
and not that you got popular because
you're good at the job exactly and i
have to say watching these people
uh in the booth and working with them
has been one of the most amazing
experiences because you're like [ __ ] you
really are that good in fact you're
better than i would have guessed like
you can do most people don't actually
realize
you know like that thing that you're
famous for didn't even test the limits
of what you can do yeah is like the
revelation we're having now it's it's it
is so cool to see those people walk in
because they're all just so friendly and
they're all so kind of very excited
about what you're doing with that that
game i can't very very interested it's
an issue you're doing it before i can
that's my main i'm just very i was
explaining it to someone for the record
it's just so it's so it's so involved
that if you if you pedal hard enough you
may beat us to market
but that's the point so like if we talk
around also your ndas is the thing about
that is like
i was explaining it to someone where i
was like i don't think this game is
going to be like a huge commercial hit
but it is
almost definitely guaranteed to be an
incredible success amongst the industry
and amongst critics because what it's
doing is so cool
i'm just i'm very
my hope is that it it i think it
actually really can be a commercial
success from the standpoint of the way
that journey was where journey
appealed to people that didn't normally
play games that was the thing that was
and that was their whole that was their
whole goal like we i remembered kelly
once when we were kelly santiago the
co-founder of tgc and the producer on
the game she was like we want to make
games for people that don't know that
they love games uh that was her little
catchphrase that i always thought was
amazing because journey was meant to
have no difficulty curve no it doesn't
rely on any kind of built-in knowledge
of the way games work you don't have to
understand what red barrels mean all
that kind of stuff
all that sort of thing is is done away
with and and there's no text or there's
no like culturally specific narrative in
fact it's it's very specifically drawing
from like the most universal narrative
possible
um all of that was by design to kind of
draw people in and and and that's um
that i think is hopefully
gonna be the same thing here like my
fantasy would be that the legions of of
like musical theater nerds who don't
really see themselves as gamers realize
oh [ __ ] this game
is like made for me uh that would be the
f because there's no difficulty there
there's no way to like do it bad or
wrong it's just choices
musical theater nerds if we love
something we love it with all our heart
like that's the that's the really
interesting thing like if you look at
like the fandoms of obviously you've got
things like hamilton but then even stuff
like uh say beetlejuice like the the the
stage show beetlejuice how that enormous
culture is growing up tick tock's going
to be a massive place for that game like
it's it's yeah if you can pull it off
the other thing is in and this brings us
full that's if if you bring it full
circle to uh to your journey album i was
i was actually going to interject while
you're talking about the whole kind of
letting people experience it new again
something that's massive with musical
theater is just like
in 10 years i want to hear the new cast
recording like that's why i collect some
jesus christ superstar cast recordings
because i love every i love the nuance
and the difference in different kind of
performances of that show
that 100 i could see here as well like
yeah 10 years from now uh what's the
what's the revival of this game sound
like you know there's there's uh there's
so what's what's the me the movie
adaptation with a bunch of uh famous
actors who are not as qualified singers
as the broadway class what does that
soundtrack sound like you know the funny
thing is it's kind of like
it's one of those that you know
obviously it would be a it would be an
amazing best case scenario if people
if it reached the level that someone
actually did want to do an adaptation or
some kind of stage version or whatever
but the idea that
taking away the player interactivity to
me seems like it would fundamentally
break the what it offers oh i just mean
that by being
that would be funny yeah now that that
uh no i but that's that to me it's
intriguing though that that it would be
it would be cool i mean the idea of an
interactive stage version is sort of
like one of those pipe dreams but i i've
thought about what the rehearsals
inherent of that would look like where
the sheer amount of rehearsing of
material that may or may not happen on a
given night is so beyond what is already
difficult rehearsal processes for a
typical
musical
um like i have friends that have done
touring shows or been on broadway for
years at a time and like that's an
arduous gig you know it's more like
immersive theater almost right or like
um
uh the galactic star cruiser thing
disney's doing or like the kind of
classic kind of immersive theater stuff
most of which relies on improv to
succeed yeah yeah
yeah or that or they have nice fashion
yeah
or in the case of like sleep no more
they'll do a thing where it's sort of
the cast is splintered where everybody
has their thing and the interactivity
comes from what you choose to look at
but but what's happening it's kind of
like in half-life in the opening where
where you look is up to you and if you
happen to look at something cool that
thing was always going to happen that
way sleep no more operates identically
to that you know there are some
interactive stage plays like you're
right that sleep no more feels like it
is because you're making a choice but
you're not actually influencing the
story it's a very old story i wonder if
there are stage plays where the audience
gets to make choices i mean again
they're all like there are i just don't
know what they would there are like
improv ones generally like and this is
true honestly at video games as well
generally there will be a string of
pearls is the way it's often described
you know this like the in and out i
imagine that's probably how most of the
stage ones are but yeah there's there's
definitely like branching narratives the
the key thing is austin says
um how a lot of these are curated is
because you're not accounting for one
player's thoughts you're accounting for
the entire audience so you often have to
break things off into branches that are
physically separate so that the person
playing or or seeing the show
experiences the path they want to go
down because if you just take a it's not
like you can do like a vote every 10
minutes on like which which thing should
happen next that would be massively
unsatisfying for the majority of the
audience um so it's
in terms of like one stage one audience
i don't know how you'd
do that be on kind of maybe doing a
survey on the way in of like hey what
kind of stories do you like and what
would what would be called more like
more like doing the improv thing of like
asking you i was gonna say that
voting system thing
i did do that once i wrote a piece i got
commissioned by the library of congress
to write a piece they were doing a video
game weekend and they said we want to do
a concert and it'd be cool to premiere a
piece that you write for this event so i
said if i'm going to do that
i would like to have the piece be
interactive to the audience and so i i
roped in rami to help me and we designed
a rudimentary app
that the audience would access
where all we did all they had to do was
basically a forward or backward arrow
and then angela created a painting that
was like a depiction of a sunset where
she had all the layers of the like a
digital painting where all the elements
were independent and then rami created a
thing where like the sun would be
gradually setting and if an if
if enough audience
started hitting the left arrow the sun
would start to rise again
and so like they could toggle time
relative to the way you saw it in this
painting in a very simple way but the
result is that it created a bran i had a
i had like a hidden monitor that the
musicians it was just violin and piano
uh but they had a monitor that was
showing at any given moment
what direction is the majority of the
audience choosing left or right and also
what is the running average so that they
they would reach these you know at the
end of bar 20 it would say
if in this moment
they are pointing left go here or go
there uh and then after a certain point
it would say it would start to reach
like three or four way splits where it
would say if in this moment they're
pointing left but the average is to the
right go here if it's average to the
left and they're currently left so that
you could create a pretty elaborate
branching sort of narrative
abstract musical terms and that way and
then so we perform the piece three times
in a row and i told the audience do
different stuff each time so that they
could hear that like if they go hard one
direction it ends up as this really
atmospheric quiet piece where the
musicians are playing really gently and
it's very kind of ethereal and then if
they make other choices it's like
violinists you know
it's like a completely different piece
and it's up to them to take it there
but it was all very abstract i don't
know how well it worked it sounds cool
that it probably was but i think that's
that's always the issue because because
some twitch players are kind of acting a
similar way right where everyone's kind
of voting and i remember when when
experimenting with some of that stuff
the challenge is it's what i said before
of like for it's very easy to cater an
experience to an individual or to or
even like in if you think about like dnd
like a table of people right like you
can kind of you can kind of dm and
curate an experience for up to about 10
people and and have them feel that
they're seeing something or experiencing
something that's their personally
influencing the second you go in that
voting direction
it becomes
more spectatory like in the end the
obviously the extreme of that is like an
election where you you vote for who
you're going to vote for but you have an
understanding going in that ultimately
your vote isn't going to move the needle
in any way that's significant but you do
it because it's a
responsibility or a duty that's where i
think these things can go if you're not
careful where if it's a big enough
audience you know that you're going to
end up with you know
no diversity of outcome essentially
you're going to end up with something
that's very and crucially as well you're
going to have a bell curve of inputs
from the players
and therefore
nearly half of people in the room are
always going to be disappointed by what
happens because it's going to be a very
close decision in a lot of cases so like
you're disappointing 45 percent of the
audience all the time which is uh which
is obviously not never a goal as an
entertainer so it's a tricky one that
doesn't mean it's impossible but it's
very tricky yeah i've i've uh i've
workshopped a lot of ideas down this
road because the idea of live because
journey live
you know
operates under this premise of
the whole audience is just watching
someone play journey but we put someone
on the stage from the audience who is
playing in earnest and and we put them
in front of the orchestra as if they
were like a soloist in a concerto you
know to say
they there's no this is not uh smoke and
mirrors and it's a video capture and
it's all just meant to look cool we
do not choreograph and we also have that
uh dev kit it was it was whitelisted on
the on the um playstation network so
that they could they could connect
online even as a dev kit with random
strangers spoken about the terrible user
names
yeah yeah right yeah
um the ultimate icebreaker at the end of
the show it's all solemn yeah so but the
um
the uh
the idea with that that was that was a
cool way to kind of solve the problem
you're talking about mike it doesn't
solve it from the standpoint that now
effectively none of the audience has
agency but the audience does see one of
themselves as a delegate on the stage
and that's their total agency i think
that's better i think that i think
because again humans are designed to be
empathic right so we're we're designed
to relate to people who we see on stage
i think that's much better than say
having you know exactly everyone have a
controller and the consensus of left or
right controls where the character goes
because you're you uk you and i'm sure
you know when that player messes up or
gets stuck that's interesting and the
audience can kind of interact and react
to that so yeah i think
theater's fascinating in that it is such
a one-directional performance usually
but it's so interactive in terms of the
actual back and forth there's there's
the the the text the text of theater is
always very directional but the subtext
is so overlapping a person coughing in
the back of the theater can throw off
the
amazing actor on stage during the most
important speech it's a it's a
fascinating back and forth that's kind
of as game designers you often want to
try and game designers we're control
freaks right we want to kind of step in
and go we have to organize everything
here and make it all work but actually
theater kind of achieves a level of
interaction that we could couldn't dream
of doing in a video game so it's
interesting and i've seen the flip you
know that that actor that gets thrown by
the cough during their sort of
traditional theater i've gone to improv
before
where
that one random cough
is the leap frog into an amazing set
piece where they're like you know what
are you walking in here with a [ __ ]
cold and it's like suddenly before you
know it they've built up this giant
thing right in front of you that is
amazing and you're like crying laughing
or or whatever and and they asked the
guy who coughed to take a bow at the end
of the show whenever it's yeah you can
you can go in a million yeah it's
awesome and that's that's where this
stuff gets messy in a way that's really
interesting is that it's
there's there's definitely direct
democratic
interaction but there's also that yeah
the the the kind of the entire audience
getting behind one person is is equal i
feel like d is probably
close to that on a smaller scale
like anything that's like a role-playing
game where you have a dm who is sure
there's a narrative structure but it
shifts in twists depending on what
players do in a way that
video games can't necessarily do is
certainly striving to but
still limited by what's written
yeah because we'll never make a piece of
code that is as creatively skilled as uh
rubbish dm is by default that's true
that's the that's the challenge
devastating but true
yeah that's that's the um
the uh
basically the whole the whole field is a
waste of everyone's time to be honest
we'll probably do something else cancel
the show you know yeah yeah we're done i
think we're done there we've solved
we've sold
finale the solution is don't make video
games
we really took a hard turn on this one
um but we should wrap up the show austin
where can people find traveler a journey
symphony
uh very kind of you um it is
uh hopefully by the time this is live it
will be on apple music for some reason
it got held up there but it's everywhere
else
spotify uh you know all like title for
the for that hardcore audiophile group
that's got to have their uncompressed
stream
uh you know etcetera etcetera there's
like a thousand retailers that you've
never heard of and then spotify and
itunes and apple music and then to my uh
amazement
uh
newly newly property of epic games i
always put things on on bandcamp of
course but to my absolute astonishment
it's literally been the number one album
on all of bandcamp for the last
congrats
which is pretty crazy because i've had a
couple albums that
managed to hold their own as the number
one soundtrack for a brief period
um
but there's just a few titles on there
that just never leave the top three like
like uh undertale
and risk of rain or just per or like
celeste they just sort of permanently
live um like just every day and journey
to you know in again it's all coming
from a place of gratitude to that
community journey is usually not far off
from that because it seems to
to you know just every day in fact i was
laughing when i was looking through the
band camp
um sort of
like um
you know notification feed that you can
access through your account of of people
buying like it shows you kind of a
real-time feed of so-and-so just paid
seven dollars so and so paid more some
people
one person
one person paid like a hundred dollars
for the album and i emailed them and i
said was this a typo because that
happened once someone paid 500 for an
album for journey years ago
and
i emailed them and i was like you're
either the most gracious person on the
planet or you accidentally
added a couple of zeros
and they wrote back this hilarious
mortified email that was like i'm a
college student that was literally
sitting here going
i don't know how i'm gonna pay my bills
this but like they were freaking out
they realized they had meant to
like they thought they needed to to put
5.00 or something like because you know
some places it just kind of fills in
relative to the period so they they uh
they've they screwed it up and they were
sitting there [ __ ] themselves when
my emails showed up and they were like i
feel
so lame and you were like
welcome to the real world and stopped
you're like this is the real world it's
time to grow
your music
they had like a tumblr
uh
like you know like blog or whatever that
they they created like this gif
montage of like the whole story of the
drama of the of the error and all that
it was one of the funniest things it was
see i actually emailed this person
thinking oh maybe this is now ten years
later the second time someone has been
broke this is the kid
this is this is that now they're an
adult
no but that they actually were like
they they said nope nope it's it's it's
on it's on purpose and the way i look at
it is bandcamp
because i put it on youtube for example
like people can find it and actually if
they go on youtube
forgive my promoting my youtube channel
but i created a hour like the whole
video there's an hour long video of the
album where angela made a painting for
each track that kind of cross-fades to a
new one they're all custom just for that
video and i put like behind-the-scenes
text over it so it's awesome if you if
you care about that i should leave a
link in the description to that that's
that would be very very kind the the um
but yeah the way i see it is bandcamp
subsidizes
like
because the per user
transaction is a like a billion times
that of a spotify stream
um which pays you know fractions of a
penny per stream the way i see it um
is those people are basically making it
easier for all the people who can't
afford it or
or don't or don't want to they don't
care enough they would enjoy the album
but they don't care enough to pay for it
to me i i like the idea of still
reaching those people and just going
well look someone else actually paid for
it for you so enjoy it on this
nonetheless like
the goal was very much always to reach
the highest number of people if the
thing makes its money back that would be
great it will take a lot
it cost you know this was all
self-financed and it will probably take
years before it could ever ever recoup
and big love to my my co-producer andrea
who who um you know we we created it
together um
uh uh and um
but uh yeah if if people want to support
it uh they are basically making it
possible for other people to do so yeah
at no cost to them and that's always
kind of
that's awesome
cool yeah i'll leave a bunch of links in
there in the description on youtube i
don't have the ability to do that on
podcast services but
check it out on all the places you get
music i'm alone
sorry i i was going to ask a question
that's completely i just
is our is our spotify and stuff you
always said that that was actually more
than than um youtube correct we do
yeah we have higher listeners on spotify
than anywhere else
it's so interesting i don't listen to
any podcast on spotify so i i i listen
to [ __ ] tons on youtube though so it's
it's why it's i don't know that's always
every time i think about that again well
the other podcast i do idiots abroad is
like
like
a hundred thousand on youtube and two
thousand on audio services i think it
depends on the show
people don't like to look at our faces
that's what it is i was gonna say i
guess the eye candy ratio is better on
that show than this one it's true it's
true it's true we austin understand but
we have a higher female audience than
that show that show is like very
male audience heavy
yeah that cracked me up the other day
yeah
uh well anyway you need to interrupt
your graceful exit
oh no i was gonna say alana adds 30
minutes of uh really bad covert advice
on this wi-fi version which makes it
very popular as well sort of you joe
[Laughter]
yeah
yeah it really helps out really helps
out they love that dispute covered every
episode i love it it's a big it's a big
thing huge win with that
what mike and troy and i don't realize
is that alana adds like 20 minutes of
voice over that only goes out on the
spotify yeah that's completely just you
know
it's all political the whole thing oh
the whole thing yeah i'm a lot i'm
videoing him right now that's mike
billy's video game director and that's
austin wintery he is a video game
composer this is play watch listen we
will see you next week
bye